STEAMING ON THE YES APP.
>> Sarah: SO THE NEW RULE
CHANGES, WE FOCUS SO MUCH ON,
AND THIS IS A PRIME EXAMPLE.
WITH JAMES HARDEN, WHAT HE HAS
DONE SO WELL.
THE LEFT OFF ARM TUCKING UNDER
AND HOOKING ALABAMA ADEBAYO.
TO SEE CONTACT AND THOSE WERE
THE CALLS THAT HE HAD
MASTERED, THIS HE USED TO GET
THAT NOW OFFICIALS ARE NOT
CALLING.
TRIES TO TUCK UNDER TO CREATE
THE CONTACT.
THOSE WERE A LOT OF CALLS THAT
JAMES HARDEN WHY MAID A LIVING
AT THE FREE-THROW LINE, FOR
HIS CAREER, A AVERAGING NINE
FREE-THROW ATTEMPTS PER GAME.
NOT GETTING THOSE CALLS.
BUT ON THE FLIP SIDE OF
THINGS.
THERE IS ALSO AS WE HAVE SEEN
A LOT OF MORE CONTACT OVERALL.
THAT'S NOT BEING CALLED ON THE
DRIVE TO THE BASKET.
>> Ian: HARDEN HAS LOGGED 30
WITHIN MINUTES, HE'S NOT NETS'